i can see why he had the kind of success
that he had
um at auburn and carolina
and talking to people from uh that were
with him there
um the things that they said about him
at auburn and the carolina from a decade
ago
or two three years ago or even last year
it is all the same
and and it showed up here um he's an
extremely hard worker nobody works
harder than cam does
he's here early he stays late and then
he works works very hard
you know some players like to work on
things that they're good at you know
like if you're strong on a bench press
and you just keep throwing more weight
on the bench
uh but cam's the type of player that um
you know works on things that he's not
as good at and
really tries to improve uh on a daily
basis and
and that's something that um you know i
really respect about him like that's not
easy for
you know for players really any of us to
do is something
look at something that we're not very we
don't feel like we're very good at or
it's not one of our strengths
and put extra time into it when you know
that's a
natural tendency is to you know do
things you're good at
bill belichick coaching during the
patriots with some high praise
recorded by cam newton before we address
that because there's plenty to dissect
there chris
yeah we we had a montage of photos
well belichick was talking and on two
different occasions
i saw who i think is josh mcdaniels it's
hard to tell with my mask on i think so
with without the mask covering the nose
people let me just take advantage of
this platform for 10 seconds and say
why even bother wearing a mask if you're
not going to cover your nose with it
and you'd like to think that people who
supposedly are
smart understand it has to cover your
nose or it isn't doing you any damn good
chris i i'm astounded when i see that
just take the damn mask off if you're
not going to cover your nose with yeah i
hear you i don't know what the issue is
we see other coaches out there with no
mask on i mean
you know again this is then take it off
if you're not covering your nose there's
no point okay
i'm with you i hear you i got you all
right you're right you're right
all right enough of that back-to-back it
drives me it drives me crazy and i don't
want to call it a pet peeve this is a
big deal
yeah you don't walk around with that
damn thing on your face wear it the
right way or don't wear it i understand
that i understand that
go ahead remember when we were talking
about bryce love
who had played with cam newton and
carolina and tom brady
kyle love not bryce love kyle kyle love
right rice love bryce loves plays for
washington kyle love is the guy who yes
who's playing defensive tackle for the
two teams
kyle love kyle thank you kyle love
said this isn't gonna work basically
because they're gonna coach this guy
hard
and they're gonna chew him out and
they're gonna beat him down
and he's been coddled his entire career
well that sure doesn't sound like
they're beating him down
that's high praise from bill belichick i
don't remember bill belichick ever
saying nobody works harder than tom
brady
is he saying that cam newton works as
hard or harder than tom brady if so
man that's something well it is
something
i mean definitely like bill belichick
wouldn't be saying that right there he
doesn't say that about people
so that must be something that jumps out
to him
and also i just feel like he was almost
saying that so cam newton could hear it
so cam newton might know like hey i
appreciate
that you work on your weaknesses and
you're doing that you know those are
things that cam newton he's going to
read that quote sometime today
someone's going to tell him about it
whatever it is and that's going to
embolden him to do it even more so
i don't know again we know we're not
going to hear from new england who's the
starting quarterback but the way they've
been talking about cam
and just the things you're hearing it
just seems like he's doing
everything and they're starting to frame
it at this guy
is our leader you know we hear about
energy we hear about julian edelman
talking about how hard he works
and what a specimen he is you're hearing
about other players mention that
and now for bill belichick to be saying
that that means he must be impressing
that way
and there's a lot to like i guess from
what bill is looking at to this point
two other observations one it's entirely
possible
that cam newton is taking it behind the
scenes right
that they're coaching him hard and that
belichick realizes
he needs to give him the praise on the
other end to get
cam to continue to buy in and not get
frustrated
with hard coaching especially once they
have game film
that they can break down in front of the
full room and maybe there's some stuff
cam newton didn't do the way he should
have
secondly we can't rule out the
possibility
that bill belichick has learned a lesson
from the way it ended with tom brady
because why did tom brady reach the end
of his rope with bill belichick
because tom brady never heard the kinds
of things that bill belichick just said
about cam newton yeah that bill
belichick withheld
his praise withheld his affection you
know there's this old school mindset
that if you spend too much time praising
someone for a job well done
they're going to get complacent they're
going to get soft they're not going to
be as hungry
they're not going to be as driven when
in reality sometimes that praise
lights your fire exactly brightly than
it already was chris
right agreed mike you know i found that
a lot of times when the coaches were
like that it made me want to do it more
made me want to be a better leader make
me work harder
man i want to play really good because i
don't want to disappoint you
coach who's been saying the like all of
that
you know so i think that's a very real
aspect and you know who knows bill might
have his reasons of why he was a little
harder on tom brady as you brent
mentioned all the time with the wes
welker thing that i've told you
they always felt like he played better
pissed off also i'm sure he knew how to
needle
brady in the correct way and all that
too but let's not forget a little bit
brady wasn't a mainstay during offseason
workouts the last few years
there was other parts of his career too
where brady he was dabbling with the
california house and being out there
not being part of the offseason i'm sure
that rubbed new england the wrong way
i mean it's new england we know it
rubbed them the wrong way
uh but i don't think this has got
anything to do
with that right now i think this is more
about this team right now
he likes what he's seeing from cam and
he's really impressed by the work ethic
and i think he's trying to encourage
that because i'm sure it's not perfect
every day out there in practice
and new england's coaches as much as
they're in your face
they have a great way how do i say this
like they don't play mind games
right there's no like it's just like hey
kim
this guy was open throw him the ball
didn't you read this will linebacker
here and what he did
and then they move on and coach the next
play they don't like give you attitude
for the rest of the day or play mind
games with you
or keep needling about it needling about
you're gonna mess up that play again
which is
what a lot of coaches do they coach you
they move on they coach the next
play and they're not into playing head
games and doing that crap that way
so i think that's where cam newton
probably is finding that refreshing too
and uh he'll be able to handle the
criticism when when there is real film
and like you're talking about
the arrival of cam newton influenced me
to put the patriots all the way at
number four
whoa the pft preseason power rankings
look
how many times do we have to see the
movie to realize that it
ends with the patriots close to if not
at the top of the mountain
right yeah so yeah the upgrade from cam
newton
uh over tom brady and we talked about
this last week
you know tom brady as of last year it's
an upgrade
over tom brady as of last yes and if cam
newton's healthy he's going to be one of
the best quarterbacks in the nfl
and and and this may end up being the
master stroke of bill belichick's career
as a personnel
evaluator getting cam newton when he was
available to
anyone getting him for a contract that
even if
he to get the full seven and a half
million seven and a half million for a
quarterback he's got to basically be the
mvp of the super bowl and the regular
season
and that unlocks a whopping seven and a
half million
i mean this may end up being as
impressive if not more impressive than
than what belichick did all those years
with tom brady if they can press the
buttons on cam newton and get him to
play like he did a few years ago
this team's going to be there when it's
all coming to a conclusion and wouldn't
it be great if it was the patriots and
the buccaneers in super bowl
oh it would be i mean that would be
unbelievable it really would be
uh i mean i'm with you how can you doubt
the patriots
you know i don't know if i would have
put them at number four where you had
them there mike
i might have had him a few spots down
like maybe behind a new orleans and a
seattle
but ahead of tampa bay like just just to
let you know where i would not that
you'd give a damn
but i'm with you you certainly can't
count this damn team out
and you know i know one thing we
discussed when cam newton first got
signed
i think there's a lot on this offense
that fits the cam newton style of
football
more than the tom brady style of
football which you know hey spread it
out
you know short passes great decisions
get it out of your hand
accurate passes that way do all that you
know i think this is a team that
wants to play a little smash mouth
football and then what we saw from brady
the last two years a little bit more of
play-action passes aggressive passing
now brady i don't think was aggressive
enough last year
and that led to the beginning of the end
for the new england patriots and brady
and all of that
but i look at i think people are
sleeping a little bit on new england's
offensive talent
i think it's a little better than people
realize i think they're going to be
creative and of course have some things
up their sleeves as far as what they can
do with cam newton
and then let's not the defense was
awesome last year and i know patrick
chung and
dante hightower aren't there but that's
not enough for me to go oh
they're going to fall off the earth on
defense no it's the best secondary in
football
there's no question about that still and
uh yeah i
expect new england to be there when
we're talking football in december for
sure
a couple of quick fill in the blanks
number one next march we will say that
the cam newton experiment with the
patriots was
what brilliant that's what i'm expecting
you know i'm getting more out of
my remember where i said i thought it
was going to be like 80 boom and there
was like a 20
bust factor of him not being able to
handle the culture and the plays and the
day-to-day details
well that's that's slowly erasing to
where i'm already at like you know
95 uh boom 5 bus because we're hearing
that that's being
overcome so yeah that's where i'm going
to go with brilliant there what about
you
i'll say entering year two that's what
it'll be doing because i think he's
gotten
obvious i think he uh but but there's no
guarantee that he's going to be back and
you don't know how he's going to react
if they have to franchise tag him how do
look if he has a great season and only
gets seven and a half million he's going
to want to get paid
after the fact for what he did last year
it's not going to be easy to do
especially if the salary cap
drops 175 million but i think they'll
find a way to get him to buy in and
stick around because if they win
and they get close to a super bowl or
get to one and if they win one he's not
going to want to leave
all right next one after julian edelman
cam newton's most productive weapon will
be who
i i tend to want or is two people i
think in this conversation to me i i
mean
i wanna say i'm gonna go in and keel
harry a guy that we did not see
a lot of as a rookie who dealt with some
injuries but he's a first-round pick
he's
big he's physical he's awesome with the
ball
in his hand and i think he's going to be
kind of their weapon guy this year mike
in a lot of ways where you might see him
on the speed sweeps and
throwing him wide receiver screens he's
got great hands as far as catching back
shoulder footballs and things like that
so it's hard hey there's muhammad sunu i
like him they signed a damir
bird from arizona he's underrated good
uh and jacoby myers of course
had a solid rookie year i think he'll be
better but my money's on and keel harry
i'm gonna have a little fun here yeah
i'm gonna have a little fun here i'm
gonna throw a dart
and you know if it doesn't hit who cares
if it does i'll claim credit for it for
the rest of my life
cam newton's most productive weapon
other than julian adam and will be
leonard fournette i'd said it that would
be leonard fournette
what would it and it's just like the
earl like we have seen this so many
times
er i'm waiting for him to sign earl
thomas i'm waiting for him to sign
leonard fournette
and i ain't gonna be surprised if he
gets both of them chris no i i hear you
mike and you know this is to me one of
the
if we have the like a question about the
offensive side of the ball to me the
running back is a little bit like
james white i almost went with him as
the weapon to watch out for
because i think again with the
misdirection in the backfield and cam
newton his ability to run
they'll be able to sneak james white out
on these you know
christian mccaffrey type routes where
cam newton hit him you know the year he
was healthy and they were six and two
and doing all that
so i look at it that way they do have
lamar miller there but running back is a
question
sony michelle has not been the guy they
had hoped him to be
as far as being a first round pick and
health being healthy has been an issue
for him
and lamar miller's coming off of an
injury so i i hear you mike i would not
be shocked if leonard fournette was you
know
uh they put a claim in for him yesterday
to get him off of waivers
and and here's the thing with cam newton
there that may be the guy who presses
the buttons to get the most out of the
net
very quickly best case worst case for
the patriots
when the super bowl lose the super bowl
i mean win the super bowl for sure
yes worst case
okay i you know i'll say worst case they
just missed out on the playoffs
okay i don't say that lightly because
but yeah the worst
worst case uh just because i i'd like to
see cam noon and this team
out on the field a little bit but you
know i could see maybe them hitting a
few bumps in the road and him being a
little off his game and getting used to
things and
maybe them not always you know executing
at a high level
so i'll say that's the worst case i
think worst case is divisional round
loss
i i this chaos is perfect for them all
of this upside
down crazy stuff and coaches complaining
about competitive disadvantage and
how do we do this bill belichick you
might just sit back
and do his thing and they are going to
be factors
this team is going to be a factor i
believe that before cam newton
i believe it even more now that cam
newton's there and i say
win the super bowl is best case and yeah
round of eight
maybe afc championship loss is worse all
right
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports